[Music]
so I have not reviewed a game in some
time and that's largely because I don't
really consider myself a game expert per
se I just really like playing games
there are plenty of youtubers and
critics out there and channels dedicated
to video games who are far better at
creating compelling game review than me
there's tons of terms I don't know
there's tons of things I don't fully
understand about the creation of a video
game I'm not passionate about creating a
video game I'm not going to game school
I'm going to film school that being said
I really want to talk about this game I
haven't reviewed a game since I think
Zelda breath of the wild and when a game
comes along that feels like it
emotionally invests me as well as gives
me a blast and I have so much fun
playing it that's everything I want in a
video game and insomniacs spider-man for
ps4 did that for me with this game you
play as a much older Spider Man he's
more experienced he's gone through a lot
of the things that were familiar with
from the films and from the comics Uncle
Ben is barely even referenced in this
game in fact you learn about his past
through backpacks that are spread
throughout the city that you can
sometimes recover if you come across one
and inside those backpacks from his
youth you find an item and he tells a
little story about said item there's so
many great in jokes there like for
instance he finds a spider plushie in
one of them and he's very excited about
that but at the same time he's sad about
it because he wasn't able to give his
rights to the company that made them
because then he would have to reveal his
identity so he didn't get any money and
he's still poor there's great Easter
eggs like that throughout the entire
game but the game does not rely on
nostalgia it doesn't rely on the past it
actually presents a very compelling
story an original story that is unique
in its own right this isn't connected to
any of the current films it's just a
fantastic game that tells an emotionally
epic story one that I found myself
really actually caring about Peter
Parker works for an organization called
feast it's a homeless shelter that Aunt
May also works for and he goes there and
he cares
for the people there and he tries to
make sure people there are fed you get
to play quite a bit as Peter Parker in
the game in fact he also works with Otto
Octavius at a lab synthesizing various
chemicals and trying to create
technology for people who have lost
limbs and you get to embark on some
scientific quests as Peter Parker you're
trying to figure out what chemical is
being dispersed into the city you know
you're looking for ways to protect the
environment or you're rerouting
circuitry to make something work you get
to use your intellect this isn't just
about swinging around New York City
which by the way is tons of fun and for
me a spider-man game kind of lives and
dies on that I'm sure there's tons of
game critics who have already said this
but I love swinging around New York City
and I did it quite often I found myself
just wanting to do that sometimes and
not even go to the Waypoint there's so
many side missions you can do sometimes
you see someone on the street and
they're shouting for you to come down
and so you can swing down and jump next
to them and they're like hey man my
friends missing and I'm not exactly sure
where he is here's a picture I found of
him it's the last place I know him to be
and then you go to try to track down his
friend Harry Osborn has set all of these
little research facilities on top of
rooftops and if you go to them you can
activate some sort of environmental
challenge something that Harry's trying
to do research on to try to protect New
York City's environment one of them was
analyzing these pigeons that may have
had the avian flu and throughout that
mission spider-man had some great quips
to say like I bet the Avengers don't
have bird poop missions which brings me
to what really excited me the most about
this game this might be my favorite
portrayal of spider-man and Peter Parker
ever I wish this was a movie this game
is easily my favorite Spiderman property
we've had since Raimi's 2004 spider-man
2 this game is everything that I want in
a spider-man game and I wish it was a
movie the cutscenes are so dramatic and
I really found myself caring because
when you're in a lab with Otto Octavius
and he's developing arms and you know
where that's leading and I was starting
to dread that because I actually gave a
I knew what would eventually happen
with him but I gave a
and I felt really terrible as his
character and his psychosis got worse
and worse the game manipulates
characters in beautiful ways Peter is
trying to reconnect with Mary Jane
Watson as well and from time to time as
you're swinging around New York City
you'll get a call from her and you you
listen to Peter trying to reconnect and
trying to find something they're looking
for that spark again and it's kind of
heartbreaking sometimes but also very
heartwarming and that's capturing what
makes spider-man possibly my favorite
superhero it's always between him and
Batman is that essence of what Peter
Parker is someone who is on the cusp of
greatness but is never fully able to
reach it because his life is always
beating him into the ground
speaking of MJ you can actually play as
her sometimes she's working for the
Daily Bugle and she's trying to break
cases she's looking at corruption going
on in the city and and you can
investigate as her sometimes you can
actually communicate with Spidey like
there's this great sequence where Spidey
is trying to take out guys one by one in
secret and MJ is moving around and being
like okay doing and you see spider-man
just come down whip up a guy and throw
them onto the ceiling that sequence was
amazing
speaking of stealth the game definitely
draws a lot from the Arkham games which
I also really enjoyed they have a lot of
similar combat situations you know
there's a lot of button mashing and when
you get to the last guy in a group enter
slow-mo for a second let's you know okay
you beat it there's definitely
inspiration drawn from that but it never
feels like it's necessarily stealing it
definitely feels like it's its own thing
there's QTE QuickTime events for some
people that might be annoying didn't
really bother me it's kind of like jump
scares I would say like you either like
him or you don't
it certainly doesn't over rely on them
if it did then it would start to bother
me J jonah Jameson has a podcast in the
game and you actually have the option to
unsubscribe from it if he bothers you
which I loved I of course stayed
subscribed because as you're swinging
around sometimes his podcast comes on
your ear and it's just hilarious
he's sort of like a modern-day
conspiracy theorist and he's just
spouting all of it about spider-man
constantly along with those backpacks
that you can track down you can
also find New York City Landmarks and
take a photo of them and you get awarded
for doing that you get experience points
there's tons of suits and and different
upgrades that are available new combat
moves are constantly becoming available
to you
and I gotta just say there's no
microtransactions and it's a
single-player game so it's kind of
everything I want and everything that
current games in 2018 aren't and I'm
gonna get into some mild spoiler
territory and I only say that because I
did not know that someone was in the
game who is in the game and I don't want
to ruin it for you if you didn't know
that so we're gonna get into some mild
spoiler territory but obviously I highly
recommend the game Miles Morales is a
playable character and I had no idea
that he was involved and it really added
a lot of nuance to the game it added so
much and you you really started to care
about this kid something I did with this
game that I like to do sometimes with
newer games is I invite someone over a
buddy of mine who isn't really involved
with like current gaming and doesn't
really know much about it I had a buddy
of mine over and he sat down he's like
I'll watch for a few minutes he ended up
watching me play this game for like
three hours because he got so wrapped up
into the story
he was so invested in it and and that's
what this game will do to you I played
the game for it for far too long really
because it's just that damn good the
spider-man character here and the
storytelling on display is sort of like
the spider-man 90s animated series
matched up with what Raimi can do with a
film and what he did with those first
two spider-man movies so well it's
everything that I want spider-man to be
and it just satisfied me way more than I
expected to because I actually bought
the game on release day and I didn't
play it for like a week after that
because I was like I'll get to it as
soon as I put that in my ps4 I could not
put the game down I'm gonna give
spider-man for the ps4 a ten out of ten
[Music]
[Applause]
I really have no problems with it I
actually sat down and was like was there
something I didn't like
I encountered a glitch once which I
captured for you guys I got stuck in a
building and I had to reset and I lost
some progress but that kind of stuff
happens sometimes but it happened one
time it wasn't like the game was broken
or anything this is clearly made with a
lot of love and I would love to see a
sequel insomniac please do that but I do
want to give a special thank you to Wix
that's the sponsor for this video Wix is
a free platform that allows you to build
highly customizable professional and
robust websites you can use the simple
drag-and-drop tools to create a
beautiful website quickly and easily Wix
takes care of the heavy lifting like
reliable hosting to keep your website
safe and secure custom domains and
mailboxes email marketing and more
complete creative freedom like infinite
design possibilities only limited by
your own imagination it's
technologically advanced they enable you
to create whatever you want yourself
whether you're a novice a business owner
or advanced designer or professional
website builder Wix is for you they
offer hundreds of templates unlimited
pages and top-grade hosting for free you
can upgrade to one of their premium
plans for as little as five dollars a
month to get even more I've wanted to
create a website for a long time for the
production company that I started when I
was 14 years old called dark forest
pictures and obviously at the time it
was just something I threw on some
iMovie opening credits because I wanted
it to look legit
I had no idea that by the time I was 30
I'd be trying to actually make it a real
company and try to produce short films
which I have done and hopefully one day
some features that's fingers crossed
what I'm trying to do right now so thank
you so much to Wix for making it fun
creative and easy and just for making it
be a process that I actually enjoyed
that website is in progress I'll
eventually have it finished I don't have
it available now but please do visit
this link to learn more about Wix and to
hopefully create a website of your own
because I do recommend their service and
thank you guys so much as always for
watching look forward to more reviews
very soon and if you like this you can
click right here and get steppen eyes
[Music]